good morning i'm lieutenant ray spencer
with the las vegas metropolitan homicide
center
las vegas metropolitan police department
homicide section i'm out here this
morning to brief you on a homicide
investigation that we are conducting in
the 6300 block
of south durango the details that i have
this morning are very preliminary but at
around 3 a.m
we received multiple calls of shots
fired at the apartment complex directly
behind me
when officers arrived there was multiple
cartridge casings that were recovered
inside the parking lot and they
discovered
that a shooting had occurred inside an
apartment
we were unable to locate a victim at
this scene
moments later a walk-in person was
dropped off
at spring valley hospital suffering from
a gunshot wound
that male was pronounced deceased at the
hospital
he is a white male in his mid-20s at
this point
we have no witnesses to the actual
shooting however i believe it is tied to
a specific apartment
behind me we urge anybody who has any
information to reach out to crime
stoppers you can do it anonymously
or you can also reach out to homicide at
lvmpd.com
again there was no witnesses that
were in the complex specifically who
witnessed it that stayed around but we
do believe there were
people that heard it but we urge anybody
who has information to reach out to us
with that i'll take a couple questions
can you describe a general area
it's in the middle of the apartment
complex in the uh
we'll call it the north uh west part of
the apartment complex
directly behind and the shell casings
were found outside of the apartment
outside so what we have discovered is
that after the victim was shot
he was transported to the hospital they
did there was a car collision
that occurred in the parking lot and
they also ran through the gate
you know trying to leave the apartment
absolutely and she said he was dropped
off at the apartment at the hospital
was there a driver at that party so we
believe
he was dropped off there's still a car
outstanding we don't know what type of
vehicle that we're looking for we're
still trying to canvas that area and
look for video
but he was we do not believe he was the
driver of that car
thank you